yeah I'll kill to this video playing F
Drive again app let him recently
let's play the shot again I remember
getting a pretty good position with that
couple of games ago I played d5 here
this is one of one of those yeah yeah I
think you need to go all the way back
just know f3 and something F 384-well
see for me it's very big Nonie then only
like it's only that luck has played this
Queen b6 means yeah something like this
is even theory as I saw this one's
interesting Bishop to c5 okay Bishop c5
I can play here yo and and covered this
but it's this is this really good for
white somehow it somehow convinces the
impression that I'm a tempo down or
something
if I take C for rupee eight it looks
terrible
yeah okay the salt so it doesn't check
look at you great but it's what I'm I
need to work now with so III did getting
this this away
check wow wow what a move this is funky
yeah I'm not sure if it is good but it
says funny move ok let's take it but now
is it before at least I've got a good
structure now this is this much is clear
the only question is ok if I go here ok
he might play Queen Queen c2 or
something but I have Queen d2 he's
giving up the dark squared bishop and if
I'm not like busted quickly here then
then I'm in good shape
this is clear with two bishops and the
space advantage the c4 pawn is also
really weak but I might be busted
quickly it is some it is entirely
possible ok rookie 4 as an important
idea probably I need to get 90 Fe please
rookie 4 F 93 looking for Fe 94th the
idea for King but as mentioned Knight c3
I thought that this would be good yes
with them a for now
the Chekhov queen III now beforethey for
saying yes but I've got a 97 97 doesn't
help
I couldn't be six check that's a big
issue I would have liked to take here
but he's got Queen b6 and I'm king g3
night aged five is a bit bit ugly to say
the least
okay let's get a square on g2 this is
the position s of Chris of course
completely wacky no idea what's
happening him Ken could be anything I
mean I could be completely lost or vice
versa
yeah yeah but this this looks nice but
I'm not sure that it is helping now I
can actually take him Queen here Bishop
e3 non-threatening 97 winning
down to one minute 18 this is this is
this is really little time I think the
position is good no I mean it's it's of
course as mentioned completely bonkers
but I don't I don't really see what what
is this night see seven now right
where's the problem
don't see it
quit be seven it's still an exchange
mm I can just take it black resigned yep
it was easy to get lost in this complete
completely crazy position so let's let's
first examine this rook takes e4 and
then I play G for the conference play g3
but okay G form and of course computer
valuation is zero zero zero it wants to
play Bishop d7 now yeah this Queen e2
supposed to be better even okay but I
took them and what's best now Queen b6
check Bishop e3 queen the ages to come
recommendation yeah all night if 494 Wow
check but take others Queen f6 check
check check check this is a perpetual
Wow
just with the Queen yeah but at zero
zero zero I believe the conch nighty
form you played this one but this losses
right yeah it does lose 94 still the
best defense should be answered by king
e - hmm I'm not
if I would have played dead this is a
better for white probably it is the
computer gives it two pawns yeah okay
this is just playing like it's like like
playing Russian roulette
you spin the wheel and hope the bullet
doesn't hit you
I now know it goes says that this is the
draw with Queen a5 crazy stuff yeah if
you want to analyze this a bit it's
especially funny thanks for watching